the following content is provided under
a Creative Commons license your support
will help MIT OpenCourseWare continue to
offer high quality educational resources
for free
to make a donation or to view additional
materials from hundreds of MIT courses
visit MIT opencourseware at ocw.mit.edu
what we're going to talk about today is
in the previous class we did a lot of
examples on some data sets and they were
artificially dated generated data sets
which is kind of a requirement in terms
of if you want to do anything with big
data and really show stuff it can be
really difficult to pass around the
terabytes and terabytes of data so
having data generators that generate the
statistics that you want or
approximately the statistics that you
want are good to have we had a previous
lecture on power law graphs and talked
about a perfect copy is very useful and
I encourage you to use that it's a
useful analytic tool this one we're
going to talk about chroniker graphs and
and and generation chroniker graphs are
used in the largest benchmark in the
world for benchmarking graph systems and
then finally I'm going to talk a little
bit about performance you know what are
the things you should be aware of when
you're when you're doing systems and
building systems from a performance
perspective the kinds of things that are
sort of centrally fundamental limits of
the technology so moving forward let's
talk about the graph 500 benchmark so
the graph 500 benchmark was created to
provide a mechanism for timing the
world's most powerful computers and see
how they good they were on graph type
operations and so I was involved and
actually wrote some of the initial code
for this benchmark about five or ten
years ago and it's now become a
community effort and the code has
changed and other types of things and
it's mainly meant for dealing with
parallel in-memory computations but the
benchmark is actually very useful for
timing databases or any types of things
you can do the exact same operations so
it generates data and then it has you
constructed in a graph and then it goes
on to do some other operations and so
we've actually found it to be a very
useful tool for just as a very fast
high-performance data generator and just
if you want to time inserts of power-law
data it's very useful for that this is
some older performance numbers but this
just shows essentially here the on a
single core of computing capability the
number of entries that we're inserting
into a table and the the inserts per
second we're getting so the single core
performance here for this data into
accumulo it's about twenty thousand
inserts per second so there's just a one
core database very very small as you've
seen we've even showed last week you
know on sort of modern servers we were
getting several hundred thousands
inserts per second on sort of a standard
standard databases I'm comparing this
also with just d4m without a database if
I just have triples and I construct an
associative array how fast does it do
that
and so obviously deep for M is limited
by how much memory that you have on your
system but it just just shows you the
constructing an associative array and
memory is is faster than inserting data
into a database by a good amount and so
again if you can work with associative
arrays in memory you're gonna you know
that's that's going to be better for you
obviously though the database allows you
to go to very large sizes and one of the
great things about accumulo is that this
line stays pretty fat flat I mean you
can go on out and out and out and out I
miss what it really prides itself on is
just that you know as you add data I
mean it might degrade slightly you know
but if you're if you're inserting it
right that that line stays pretty flat
in the last class we did show how to do
parallel inserts and parallel deform
this just shows you know parallel
inserts here on a single node database
you know D for M itself you know
basically just taking this number and
scaling it up and also into the database
and so here a you know single node
database single node single
core database who are getting like a
hundred thousand inserts a second with
with that and so so you know that just
shows you kind of some of the parallel
expectations and when you should use a
parallel you know parallel versions
databases again if you can be in memory
you want to be in memory it's faster if
you can be in parallel memory you
probably want to be in parallel memory
that's faster but if you have really
large problems then obviously you need
to go to the database and that's what's
that that's for the the data in the top
500 I mean the graph 500 benchmark is
what we call a chronica graph it
basically takes a little tiny matrix ok
little seed matrix in this case G and
you can imagine kind of what it looks
like here sort of imagine this is a 2 by
2 matrix here you can sort of see you
know maybe a little bit of the structure
and then it just does a chroniker
product of that on out to create an
adjacency matrix of you know by creating
this J summation that creates the graph
and and as a result it naturally
produces this is a result it produces a
something that naturally looks like a
power-law graph here and this just shows
you the dots show you the power law a
degree distribution of that and you can
see the sort of the slope there and from
generated from this I should say one of
the powerful things about this
particular generator is uh you you don't
have to form the associate of the
adjacency matrix to construct the graph
so it doesn't require you to build this
gigantic matrix it generates the edges
sort of atomically um if you have many
many processes all doing this as long as
they set the random number seeds to
different locations they'll all be
generating perfectly consistent edges in
a larger graph so it makes it very in
this so people have run this on
computers with millions of course to to
do that because the the
the graph generator is completely a
parallel allows you to essentially
create a giant a giant graph and and
also the chronicle graph though does
generate the structure here which is
these these bumps and Wiggles and that
actually corresponds to the power K so
you can count the number of bumps we
have one two three four five six seven
eight so this would be a G to the eighth
graph so that structure is is visible
there which is an artificial feature of
the data and so one of the things that's
actually occurred now with is that
people have been actually trying to use
this generator because it's so fast and
efficient to to simulate graphs and and
we've basically said to people you know
not not really designed to simulate
large graphs because it does create
these artificial structures in there and
it's kind of the reason we developed the
perfect power law method because that's
a much better method if you're actually
trying to simulate graphs for doing that
again this math that has these
advantages in terms of being able to
generate them another advantage of these
of these chronica graphs and so in this
case B is my little matrix here that I'm
going to do about chroniker products of
in fact let me remind you about what a
Kronecker product is so if I have here a
matrix B that's NB by NB although these
don't have to be square and another
matrix C that's NC by NC doesn't also
have to be square and they do the
Kronecker product basically what you're
doing is essentially taking C and
multiplying by the first element and
having essentially a block here and so
it's a way of essentially expanding the
matrix in both both dimensions and Ouray
less Kovach who's now a professor at
stanford essentially developed this
method back at 2005 for for creating
these matrices which allow you to very
naturally creates for power law matrices
and even have tools for fitting them you
know to data which is a useful useful
thing again it's it's its biggest impact
has been on on generating very large
graphs power-law grass very quickly the
chroniker graph itself has several
different types so that I call here
basically explicit stochastic and an
instance so if I just set the
coefficients of the Kronecker graph to
be like ones and zeros and I chroniker
out I will get structures that look like
this so this is a chronica graph it
essentially is a bipartite essentially
starting with a do you call a star graph
and then a diagonal so that's kind of
one that's gg1
then i pranic our product again G 2 and
G 3 and I get these sort of different
structure 0 1 matrices and so it's only
zeros and ones and so the structure and
the connections are very obvious and
this is actually useful for doing theory
so you can actually do a fair amount of
theory on the structure of graphs using
these 0 1 matrices the even in fact
there's a famous paper by Van LOM on
chroniker products and it's basically
the paper is full of identities of
chroniker products that you know the
eigenvalues of the the Kronecker product
of two matrices is the same as the
Kronecker product of their eigenvalues
and and just a whole series of those
things and so what's nice is if you
compute something on just this the cart
the the small matrix G you can very
quickly compute all the properties of
the chroniker product matrix and that
makes it very nice for doing theory and
so there's times when you want to to
sort of understand the structure of
these things very useful theoretical
tool for doing that if instead if we use
our little RC graph instead of it being
ones and zeroes it contains say numbers
between zero and one that are
probabilities the probability of an
accrediting an edge between those two
vertices and we multiply that on out you
getting to get essentially a giant
probability matrix showing the
probability of edges all right these are
the same but here we see we have
differences we don't just have zeros and
ones we have values between zeros and
ones and then using the chronic
regeneration technique we essentially
draw instances from this probability
matrix over here so this allows us to
search randomly sample so when you
talked about Connor craps there's kind
of three different types here this is
kind of very easy to do theory on you
can do theory on this too although it
tends to you know be a little bit more
working and then likewise when you're
doing simulations usually you end up
with with chroniker graphs like this as
an example of the kind of theory we can
do one of the nicest graphs to work with
our bipartite graphs so bipartite graph
is a set of vertices two sets of
vertices that have and each vertex has a
connection to every vertex and the other
set but they don't have any connections
amongst themselves and so here I'm
showing you a bipartite R star graph so
basically a one set of vertices here and
another set of vertices here and all the
vertices have connections to live its
vertex but they have no connections
themselves and this is the adjacency
matrix of that graph and here is another
bipartite graph it's sort of a 3:1 set
and if I chroniker product to bipartite
graphs the result is two more bipartite
graphs so as we see here we've created
this one here and this one here and and
and so in my notation I'll say be five
comma one is a byte art art that's
basically I'm saying I have a matrix
that's a it's a five you know five one
bipartite graph three one bipartite
graph and with on within some
permutation they produce a matrix that
is the union of a 1501 and a
five okay and this result is actually a
result was first shown by a professor by
name of Y Show in 1962 you know and
there was actually a little flurry of
act of activity back in the 1960s with
this whole algebraic view of graph
theory and and then and then which was
very productive but then it all died off
and after the lecture I can tell you why
that happened but now it's all coming
back which is nice so it took us 50
years to rediscover this work but
there's actually a full book on it with
lots of interesting results and so but
then this just shows you kind of the
general result here is that you know for
any two bipartite graphs by chroniker
problems together they are under some
permutation equal to you know to other
bipartite graphs and this sort of
naturally shows you how the power law
structure gets built up when you
chroniker product these graphs so
basically you know you had this and this
and there we basically at you know crude
that's the super node vertex here this
one one vertex and these are the lower
degree pieces and then these other
vertices here are the singleton vertices
so you can see as you naturally by part
you know a product these bipartite
graphs together you naturally create
these power law power law graphs in just
an example I won't really labor the
details here you can compute the degree
distribution so this is this is and this
is all there's like a long chapter on
this in the book basically you can
compute analytically the degree
distributions of Kronecker product in
bipartite graphs this shows you the
formula for doing that and here is the
actual degree distribution with the
binomial coefficients for the four for
that and so a very useful thing you can
do that this shows you the results so if
I have a chronica product of a
part I graph n equals five comma one and
I take it out to the tenth power this is
the theater this is the result is this
blue line and what you see is that you
get if you connect the last vertex and
this vertex essentially did our poor
man's alpha or connected any one of
these other sets here they have a
constant slope of negative one so that's
a theoretical result is that they have
this this constant slope and that's true
down here you know K to K to the five
other types of things so we do get this
bowing effect so it's not perfect with
respect to that but but you can see how
this power law is sort of baked into the
chronic or generator which is a very
nice nice nice thing this just shows a
sample and we basically created a
bipartite four by one by tart drug graph
and then sampled it and so this shows
the stochastic instance there's about a
million vertices here shows you that and
then these curves here show when we take
the stochastic graph and analytically
compute what the expected value of every
single degree is assuming a Poisson
distribution and you can see that we
that we get a pretty much a perfect fit
here okay all the way out except to the
very end here and this is where you get
some pretty interesting statistics going
on in theory right no one vertex you
know you should this is your
distribution right no one vertex should
actually be you know attracting as many
nodes but you have so many vertices with
one of them that have this problem when
you sum them all together one of them
gets to be chosen to be the winner and
it's what pops it up here so all the way
out to the soup you know our fit is very
good all the way out to the super node
and we have this difference here and
this is where kind of the the plus on
statistics begin to fail so again lots
of opportunities for very interesting
very interesting theory there
so that's just pure bipartite graphs but
bipartite graphs have no intergroup
connections so we can actually create
something that looks like a power-law
graph and see all the sub community
substructure and very clearly but those
communities are not connected in any way
and so to create connections in the
communities we have to add the identity
matrix down the diagonal and that will
then now connect all our our sub
bipartite graphs together so this just
shows here so we basically take our
bipartite graph a plus identity and
that's essentially this sort of by know
this combinatorial sum here of the
individual bipartite graphs there again
we're in quotes means that there's a
permutation you need to actually make
this all work out we actually do the
computation all right
this shows the pipe the the 4 comma 1
bipartite plus an identity bipartite
graph out to the fourth power so you see
here you're gonna get 1 2 you can
compute it on out there and what you see
is sort of this recursive structure
almost fractal like structure so that's
a nice way to view it you know that's
one way to kind of see it but you don't
really see the bipartite substructure in
there it's hard to R to see what's going
on there well since this is analytic we
can actually compute a permutation that
says please recover all those bipartite
sub structures and so in the software
actually we've distributed we have a way
of basically computing a permutation of
this that basically regroups all our bar
pipe all our bipartite groups here and
then you can see all the bipartite the
core sort of bipartite pieces and then
all the interconnections between those
core bipartite pieces to give you a
better sense of what that really means
so here basically we have we have B to
the I to the third power here
right that's what it looks like if we
just subtract out the first and second
order components then we're left with
these are the inner connecting pieces
you can see that much better when we
permute it so here is the permutation of
just the bipartite please and that shows
you these core bipartite trunks that are
in the graph we then do the second term
which is the cron B cron I so this is a
second now you can see that this creates
connections between these groups all
right and then likewise if you do the
the next one so be you know be cron I be
that shows you the connections between
these groups and then IBB shows you the
different connections in these groups so
each set of when we take B plus I and
multiply it out and look at all those
different combinations of the different
multiplies there you know there's the
core piece which is just be cron to the
three and then an all and that creates
this core structure here which is these
densest pieces and then all the other
polynomials our sense of creating
interconnections between that so you can
get really deep understanding of the
core structure and how those things
connect together which can be very
interesting we can compute these
interconnected structures fairly nicely
here's a higher-order example going out
to the fifth ok but we can compute the
structure this Chi structure which is
essentially a summary of these by just
looking at a two by two so we can
compete all the structures of the
interconnections by just looking since
we have a bipartite thing we can
collapse all those pieces down and just
have a two by two so we have here a
little tiny version of this structure it
shows you that likewise this structure
here is summarized by that and this
structure here is summarized by that so
you can get come complete knowledge not
just at the low level scale but at all
scales if you wanted to say I want to
look at the blocks and how the edges are
connected in detail or if I just want to
consider
things in big blocks and connect them I
can do that very nicely as well and
again we can compute the degree
distributions as well so this just shows
be Kron to the K and then B plus the
second order terms and then moving on
out and actually what you see is by
adding this identity matrix all does
sort of slide the degree structure over
it also does change the slope a little
bit here by adding this identity matrix
along so it's steeper than the original
and you can do other types of things
like here's something we did an
isoparametric ratios I won't belabor
that but it essentially way of computing
the surface to volume of sub graphs and
we can compute this analytically and we
see the isoparametric nature of a
bipartite sub graph is constant but the
half bipartite graph has this property
here and just to summarize here and this
has done a great deal in chapter this
just shows different examples of the
theoretical results you know you can
compute for for bipartite graph or a
bipartite plus an identity you know the
degree distribution Abadie unit between
the centrality is a fairly complicated
metric we actually haven't figured out
for this one there right I didn't bother
to figure it out for this one you can
compute the diameter very nice you can
compute the eigenvalues and the
isoparametric ratios are just all
examples of the kind of theoretical work
you can do and again I think it's very
useful if you want to kind of really
understand the substructure and how the
different parts of a power-law graph
might interact with each other all right
so that just talks about kind of
chroniker graphs and so and which are
the basis of these benchmarks and now
I'm going to get into some benchmarks
again themselves so this just to remind
folks this just shows some examples of
when you're doing a benchmarking of
inserts into a database a normally we do
parallel computing of kind of one
parameter which is how many parallel
processes are you running at the same
time and so most of your scaling curves
will be with respect to in this case
the number of the number of concurrent
processes that you're running at one
time here I think we're going up and up
going up to 32 here that's the standard
parameter in parallel computing when you
have parallel databases involved now you
have a couple of additional parameters
which just make it sort of that much
more stuff you have to keep in your head
which is essentially in this case an
accumulate all as its individual data
servers tablet servers so you have to be
aware of how many tablet servers you
have so that's another parameter so you
have to create separate curves here this
is our scaling curve with a number of
ingest processes into one tablet server
versus number of n just processes into
six tablet servers and as you can see
you know they don't not a huge
difference here at the small end but
eventually the one tablet server a
database sort of levels off while the
other one keeps on scaling and so this
is very tricky I mean if you want to do
these kind of results you kind of have
to be aware of both of these parameters
you know in order to really understand
what your what you're doing there's also
a third parameter which is generally
true of most databases in the cumulus no
exception which is that if you're
inserting to a table a table into a
parallel database that that table is
going to be split amongst the the
different parallel servers in the
database and that will have a big impact
on performance how how many splits you
have because you're not going to be able
to take advantage of few fewer splits
than the number of database server nodes
then you're not taking advantage of
those and then how balanced those splits
are there are is the data going in
uniformly into those into those things
and so this just shows you an example of
an eighth tablet server accumulo doing
the inserts with no splits versus doing
it in this case with 35 splits and you
see there's a rather large impact on the
performance there so a deform actually
has tools we didn't really go for into
them but if you look at the look at the
documentation for allowing you to do
splits the databases we've given you
access to are all single node
so we made your life in certain sense a
little bit easier that you don't have to
worry about splits but it is something
as you work on larger systems you have
to be very well aware of the splits
another thing that's often very
important is when you're inserting into
a database is the chunks of the size of
the chunks of data that you're handing
to the database this is sometimes called
the block size this is a very important
parameter blocking of programs is very
important you probably key thing we do
in optimizing any program is coming up
finding out what the right block size is
for a system because it almost always
has a peak around some number here and
so this just shows the impact of block
size on the performance rate here for
accumulo and nice thing about d4m
there's actually a parameter you can set
for the table which will say how many
bytes I want to set I think the default
is like 500 kilobytes which is a lot
smaller than I would have thought but
it's a number that we found tends to be
fairly optimal across a wide range of
things typically when you do inserts a
new database you're like well I want to
give you the biggest chunk that I can
and move on and it caming oh and
probably a lot of native is actually
like to get data in smaller chunks than
you would then you would then you might
think basically what's happening then is
if you're giving it the right sized
chunks then that it all fits in cache
and any sorting and other types of
operation has to do on that data can be
done much more efficiently so this just
shows another parameter you have to be
worried about if you do everything right
and I showed this show these results
before these are the kind of results
that you can get this shows essentially
on an eight node system fairly powerful
24 cores per per per node getting the
four million inserts or entries per
second that we saw which is to our
knowledge again the world-record holder
for this that talks about inserts
another thing that we also want to look
at is queries so as I said before
accumulo is a row base too
which means if you give it a row key it
will return the result in constant time
and so that's true so we've done a bunch
of queries here lots of different
concurrent processes all querying at the
same time and you can see the the
response time is you know gently they
say around 50 milliseconds which is
great you know this is the full
round-trip time a lot of this could have
been network latency for all we know and
so that's what you expect that's what
accumulative urgency would you wrote
queries then you get constant time now
as we've talked about before we do our
special exploded transpose schema which
essentially give this performance for
both row and column queries but if you
have a table where you haven't done that
and you are gonna query a column it's a
complete scan of the table and so you
see here as you and just you know when
you want to do a column query you know
the performance is just gonna go up and
up and up and up and because they're all
just doing more and more scans and the
the system can only scan a certain rate
so that's again the main reason why we
do these special schemas is to avoid
this performance penalty so finally in
talking about performance let's talk a
little bit about d4m performance itself
if you write your d4m programs optimally
and this sometimes takes a while to get
to because usually you don't quite have
there but I should say in the most
elegant way possible again this
sometimes requires some understanding
most applications end up becoming a
combination of matrix multiplies on
these associative arrays now it's
usually not the first program I write
but usually is the last one I write for
this like I finally dawns on me to how
to do the entire complicated analytic
and all its queries as a series of
special sparse matrix multiplies which
then allows us to maximally leverage the
underlying libraries which have been
very optimized to do you know I'm it's
basically not calling
any of my code it's just calling the
MATLAB sparse matrix multiply routine
which is further calling the sparse
applause which are heavily optimized by
the vendor the computing vendors and
likewise recalling sort routines so the
thing you have to understand though is
that sparse matrix multiply as
fundamental Hardware limits depending on
the kinds of multiplies you're doing
here so and we have a whole program that
basically times all these and generates
them so if you ever want to get what
your fundamental limits are we have a
set of programs that will run all these
benchmarks for you and show you what you
can expect if you're and this shows you
basically the fraction of the
theoretical peak performance of the
processor as a function of the total
memory of the on that processor so so
this is all single core single processor
benchmarks so as you can see here this
is dense matrix multiply and it's like
95% efficient if I was to build a piece
of special purpose hardware and a memory
subsystem for doing dense matrix
multiply it would be identical to the
computers that you all have your
computers have been absolutely designed
to do dense matrix multiply and for good
or bad that's just the way it is the
caching structure the the the matrix
multiply units the vectorization units
they're all designed to do they're
identical to an you know a custom-built
matrix multiply unit and so we get
enormous ly high performance here
ninety-five percent speak on dense
matrix multiply unfortunately that
hardware architecture and everything we
do it for dense matrix multiply is the
opposite of what we would do if we built
a computer for doing sparse matrix
multiply and that's why we have when we
go from dense matrix multiply to sparse
matrix multiply this thousand X drop in
performance okay and this is not getting
better with time this is getting worse
with time
and there's nothing you can do about it
that is just what the hardware does now
it's still better to do sports make sure
multiply than to convert it to dents
because you're still a net win by not
storing computing all those zeros that
you would have in a very sparse matrix
so it's still a significant win in in in
in execution time to do your calculation
on sparse matrices if they are sparse
but but not otherwise
and then so that's that
this shows sparse the matrix multiply of
an associative right so the first one
the top one is MATLAB dense MATLAB
sparse d4m associative array and we
worked very hard to make the d4m
associative array just to be a constant
you know factor below the coarse par so
you're really getting performance that
is pretty darn close to that and so you
know generally doing sparse matrix
multiplies on the associative arrays
works out pretty well but again these
are still like about 0.1% efficient of
the hardware and then the final thing is
we have these special sparse matrix
multiplies where we concatenate the keys
together if you remember way back when
we did the bioinformatics example we
could do special matrix multiplies that
that essentially preserved where the
data came from if we correlated to DNA
sequences we would you know have a major
matrix that would show the IDS of the
DNA sequence and if we did these special
matrix multiplies the values within
whole the exact DNA sequences themselves
that were the matches well there's a
performance hit that comes with holding
that additional information just all
this string information and maybe one
day we'll be able to optimize this
further although we've actually
optimized it a fair bit already and so
there's another sort of factor of a
hundred and it looks like this is just
again fundamentally limited by the the
speed at which we can the hardware will
do sparse matrix multiply and the speed
at which it can do string sorting that's
essentially the two
teams that these all these functions
boil down to a sparse matrix multiply
and string sorting and those are
essentially hardware limited those are
very optimized functions so this just
gives you a way I think it's always and
it's the first thing we do when we run a
program is you know if we want to
optimize it we'll run the right to
program and running at a time and then
we'll try and figure out you know based
on this type of data well what's the
theoretical best we could do you know
what's given the kind of what this
calculation is dominated by what is the
best we can do because if the best we
could do the theoretical peak was I mean
up for what we were doing was a thousand
times better than what we're doing that
tells us you know what if we have to
invest time in optimization it probably
is time well spent going from being a
thousand X below whatever the best is
you can do getting to a hundred X
usually doesn't take too much well
usually you can find what that issue is
and you can correct it okay likewise
going from 100 X to 10x is still usually
a worthwhile thing to do if you if
you're at like 10 percent of the best
that you can do then you begin to think
hard about well do I really want to
chase I'm never gonna probably do better
than 50 percent of what the best is you
know or maybe even 30 or 40 percent
usually there's a lot of effort that
goes into going from 10 percent of peak
performance to 50 percent of peak
performance but going from 0.1 percent
of peak performance to 1% of peak
performance is usually profile the code
aha I'm doing something wrong here fix
it done and so this is something that's
a part of our philosophy and doing
optimization and why we spend so much
time running benchmarks and
understanding where we where because it
tells us when to stop if someone says
well will this be faster you can say no
won't be faster when you're done or at
no we think in a few weeks times we
really can you know we can really make
a lot better so very useful thing and
that's why benchmarking is a big part of
what we do so finally I want to wrap up
here this was one of the first charts I
showed you and hopefully now it makes a
lot more sense this shows you the easy
path towards solving your problems and
signal processing on databases all right
and if you look at your problem as one
of how much data I want a process and
how much you know what the granularity
of access is well if I don't have a lot
of data and I'm accessing it at a very
small granularity well then I should
just do it in the memory of my my
computer don't mess around with files
don't mess around with databases keep
your life simple work it there if the
data request gets high memory is still
the best whether you're doing little
bits or big that's you know working out
a main memory on a single processor
generally for the most part is where you
want to be if you're gonna be getting to
larger amounts of data but having a
fairly large request size then using
files reading those files in and out so
basically you know if I have a lot of
data I want to process it won't fit into
serial memory will write it out in a
bunch of files just read them in process
them move on to the next file is the
right thing to do or spread it out in
parallel run a bunch of nodes and use
the RAM in each one of those that's
still the best way to do it you can also
do that in parallel you can have
parallel programs reading parallel files
to so if you have really enormous
amounts of data and you're gonna be
reading the data in large chunks then
you want to use parallel files parallel
computing that's gonna give you better
performance and it's gonna be easy I
mean you know have a lot of files each
program reads in two sets of files
processes it's set very easy to do and
we have lots of support in our elegant
system for doing those types of problems
that's the thing that most people do
however
if you have a large amount of data and
you want to be accessing small fractions
of it randomly that's when you want to
use the database that is the use case
for the database and there are
definitely times when we have that case
where we want to do that but you want to
kind of build towards it a lot of times
when you're doing analytics or algorithm
development you tend to be in these
cases first and so rather than bite off
the complexity associated with dealing
with a database use these tools first
but then eventually there may be a time
we actually have to use the database and
I hopefully one thing you get out of
this course is understanding this nuance
type of thing because a lot of people
say we need a parallel database why we
have a lot of data all right that's
great well what do you want to do what
we're gonna scan over the whole thing
well that's just gonna be a lot of data
really slow you know and then some
people will do that to load a bunch of
atap in the system like well but
nothing's faster you know it's like well
yeah if you're gonna scan over a
significant fraction in the database it
will be slower certainly slower than
loading it into the memories of a bunch
of computers and and even slower than
just having a bunch of files and reading
them into memory so and increasingly
nowadays you know I mean so what you
know you're talking about this is like
millions of entries you know there's a
lot of things that were databases that
we have like the labs LDAP server it's
like 30 thousand entries we have a
database for it you could send it around
an Excel spreadsheet and you know pretty
much do everything with that or the
entire release review query or the
phonebook or whatever these are all now
by today's standards
microscopic data sets that contributes
toward in a single associative array in
something like this and manipulated to
your heart's content so there's a lot of
data sets that are big to the human but
are microscopic to the technology
nowadays so this is usually millions of
entries you know this might be hundreds
of millions of entries definitely when
you
you know often you're talking about
billions of entries when you're getting
here to the point where you'll really
need a database the exception to this
being if you're in a program that
requires you know money of our customer
will say the database is being used this
is where the data is it's in no other
place so for integration purposes then
you throw all this out the window right
if they say look this is where the data
is and you have that's the only way you
can get it then of course but that still
doesn't mean you might be like yeah well
you're gonna store in the data is but
I'm gonna store it in slash tent and
work on it and then put my results back
in the database because I know that what
I'm doing is it's gonna be better
there's there's no you know don't as I
say you know we don't want to be too
proud to win you know just because in
date you know sometimes like we have a
database and everything must be purely
done in the database or some people like
we have system and everything must be
purely done in the file system or we we
have this language and everything the
right tool for the job you know the
right tool for the job pulling them
together totally fine it's a quick way
to get get this work done without
driving yourself crazy
so with that I'll come to the end I have
one code example which is relatively
short to show you but again you know
parallel graphs or the dominant type of
data we see you know graph 500 realizing
this chronica product chroniker graph
theory is a great theoretical framework
for looking at stuff you get all the
identity benefits that come with with
chroniker product i get values if you're
into that i certainly suggest you to
read the van loan paper which is also
this the salmon will work on on
chroniker products and I don't think
anyone's written a follow up to it
because everyone's like yep covered it
there it's about 1215 pages covered all
the properties of Kronecker products we
can do parallel computing and deform by
a P MATLAB and again the the
fundamentally if you've implemented your
algorithms correctly they're limited by
hardware okay by fundamental aspects of
the hardware there are limitations is
important to know what those are and to
be aware of them so